my name is stephen goldfarb and i'm a
physicist from the university of
michigan so i'm david barney
i'm a physicist for the cms experiment i
work for cern well i'm working on the
atlas experiment on the large hadron
collider speaking of which you might
have noticed it is behind my back i've
been working for cms now for
19 years oh yeah i see it yeah is that
is that that which one is it is it that
is it that massive the size of a
cathedral yeah you can just just around
there you can you can sort of make it
out
the thing we got asked the most about
was people wanted to know a little bit
about the computing power and how you
compute
all the data coming out of this detector
so at the moment when we have the the
proton collisions happening we can
create up to a nearly a billion
collisions every second
and we take a snapshot
of what's going on about 40
40 million times a second we're beyond
giga right okay terra pettit we're in a
petabytes okay so so this this thing
here all of the each one of these tubes
gives us some data
when at the end of the day we'll
actually every 30 million times a second
this guy gives us about a a petabyte of
data so about a petabyte of data comes
out per second a petabyte
now we can't possibly store all of those
snapshots
in any
known storage medium so what we have to
do is we have to decide very quickly
whether one of these snapshots is
interesting and one of them's rubbish
and we can just throw it away so what
happens a petabyte of data comes out it
goes down these cables here it goes all
the way out it goes downstairs and it
goes into this this room that's full of
electronics the electronics brings it
all in and then it filters it it makes
very fast decisions and says i i like
this i don't like that and it throws
away the vast majority of it
so when we're all done at the end of the
day instead of taking uh 30 million per
second we keep a few hundred events per
second that's still petabytes per year
what we can actually store
for further analysis is only about 100
of these snapshots every second so we
have a very complex
system
uh called the trigger
that tries to decide very quickly
whether the thing's interesting or not
and it has two levels the first level is
based on electronics hardware
that
takes a global view
of the whole
detector information and tries to say
very quickly
yes this is good this is bad
and it takes the rate down from 40
million a second down to about 100 000 a
second
then
all of the data from those hundred
thousand
go to
a farm of computers we call it a farm
because it looks like it's just one
computer after another
and that farm of computers analyzes in
detail what happened in this collision
tries to find the most interesting ones
and then stores about between 100 and
300 of those really interesting
snapshots
for further analysis that further
analysis can be done anywhere in the
world
through a distributed
very powerful computer system called the
grid how do you guys know you're not
throwing away good stuff because you're
throwing away so much oh yeah you know
well actually some of the data that we
keep uh is just random
so we have a we have a what we call a
trigger menu all the things that we
would like to have for breakfast okay so
we have this whole menu there and we say
okay i want the higgs on super symmetry
i know what that might look like what
that might look like we go down that
whole menu and we pull out the events
that would fit that but then we also
have something which says just grab some
at random grab some at random and we
call that our minimum bias sample so we
always can check
our efficiencies and we can check to see
if we missed something when you say a
snapshot what do you mean by a snapshot
and is this like you know
four or five megabytes like a photo i
take with my camera how big is a
snapshot
so the cms detector if you like is is a
75 megapixel camera
so my iphone has 5 megapixels so 75
doesn't really sound very impressive
difference is we take 40 million a
second
but most of the information
most of these detector elements are
actually empty there's nothing there
because we don't get particle going
through every single part of the
detector at once
so in fact each of these snapshots
eventually
is down to a level of about a megabyte
so one megabyte is what we actually
store per snapshot even that in itself
to try and store 100 megabytes or 300
megabytes per second
is a massive deal it's like filling a cd
every couple of seconds
it's noisy
it's
it's like if you've been on a on a ship
on um
you know across across the english
channel or something and you're you're
on you're on the the hum of the engines
constantly the hadron color limiter
and then within that you've got the the
inner detector and the pipe itself so
literally it's deep within that is where
all where it's all going on where it's
all kicking off